next week on the bachelor shalon
thanks for having this chat with me tell
me about yourself
well i'm an artist i like to read
and what else oh every few weeks i have
to form a new identity in order to cope
with life
sounds complicated not gonna lie
yeah well i'm pretty much here just to
help my brothers pay off their debt
so it's been fun talking to you wait
wait i i have a super
super tragic backstory i i guess
you could stay on another week awesome
and
uh oh don't worry i'm already coming up
with a new personality i know you'll
love
oh really let's hear a little bit of
that uh
do you ever take a dump in your shard
plate what the [ __ ] oh you know what i
mean a numero dose
that's not even a language in this
universe a a poopy in the shard pants
a farty in the shardy you know what
shalon as a matter of fact i
have and it felt better than peeing in a
lake sorry mind if i steal him for a sec
he's all yours cal i just wanted to tell
you that
you're an idiot storming bridge boy
don't worry you're getting a rose